there is a new war on christmas
for republicans that's playing very
heavily
on fox news and other right-wing media
and it is
so-called cancel culture now never mind
the irony
of people who supposedly have been
canceled and silenced
regularly appearing on national
television like fox news to claim that
they no longer have a voice
i understand the irony of that and the
absurdity of that
let's put that aside for a second okay
we are now going to look at clips of the
fourth type of response we're seeing
to the outrageous and disgusting
comments made by republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor green so
let me catch you up
on the three types of responses we've
looked at so far
republican steve scalise went with
attack joe biden when asked about
marjorie taylor green
we saw that yesterday that's response
type number one
republican congresswoman nancy mace said
there are crazies on both sides when
asked about marjorie taylor greene
that's the second response a
whataboutism type of thing
republican senator lindsey graham as we
just saw
said maybe the comments were taken out
of context which in this case
is a form of gaslighting that's the
third type of response
we saw from republicans and now response
type number four
is republican congressman jim jordan a
disgusting person by all accounts going
with
if we were to punish marjorie taylor
greene
it would be the cancel culture he
actually
says in this first clip from fox news
yesterday
think of the cancel culture let's watch
and listen
so there are many members of your own
party who are taking issue here
let's take a quick break and listen to
karl rove on this
very issue and we'll get your response
congressman
if you believe that the jews control a
space laser that
that that starts fires in northern
california
and that there's some unnamed
high-ranking government official who's
got a heretofore unknown security
classification called
cue and all the nutty things that flow
with that you should be taken off the
prestigious
house education labor committee and
confined to the dark recesses
of the of of the furthest building away
from the house floor
and then let the voters decide in the
next election she is a problem for our
party
congressman your response no one no
one's condoning the
remarks that she made i've not heard any
republicans say that those were
appropriate
so that's not the issue the issue is
once this starts tell me where it in
sandra
where does it who's next let me look
think of the cancel culture sandra i
said this on january 13th on the house
floor during debate
i told the democrats if you guys keep
going down this road keep attacking
people they're first in them at free
speech rights
where does it end it won't stop with
republicans it'll go it'll go to all of
us
and 13 days later what happened in in
california
dianne feinstein's elementary school's
name was taken off
so this will this will never end and if
we don't stop it now
everyone every single american's at risk
and that's what concerns me
so jim jordan a republican from the
party
of so-called personal responsibility is
saying there
if there are ever consequences to
people's speech
it's cancelled culture and it's bad
there cannot be
consequences to speech per this
statement from jim jordan jim jordan
appears to believe
that free speech includes total immunity
from having your speech lead to
repercussions
and then jim jordan actually has the
audacity to say
in the middle of a global pandemic that
still killed 4 000 people yesterday
case is plummeting hopefully deaths will
soon but still killing 4 000 people a
day
jim jordan has the audacity the
testicular fortitude
to say that cancel culture is the most
dangerous thing happening in the united
states today
but you know what we have a first
amendment what i don't want is people
canceling everyone else
that is the most dangerous thing
happening in our country today
right now joe biden says during his
inauguration speech he wants to unify
well it's tough to unify when you're
impeaching a president who's already
left office it's tough to unify
when you're trying to cancel 75 million
people who voted for that guy
that is what's tough to do so i hope we
can get past this i hope we can get back
to embracing the bill of rights
now most people upon hearing that will
realize that nothing he's saying makes
any sense
but this idea that any consequence to
speech
is an infringement on the first
amendment is a really dangerous idea and
unfortunately there are lots of
americans who watch fox news and think
you can learn about the first amendment
by watching fox news
and that's really scary because they end
up believing this stuff
imagine the most dangerous thing not the
virus
not the people who rioted at the capitol
on january 6th
not the dangers of allowing more and
more time to pass without passing
coveted relief
cancel culture by which he means
consequences for marjorie taylor green's
insane comments
that is the most dangerous thing facing
the country
replace the words cancel culture with
consequences and reinterpret this
consequences for disgusting speech would
be the most dangerous thing in the
country
what accountability is a slippery slope
according to jim jordan and in truth if
you know anything about jim jordan's
history
jim jordan's the last guy who should be
telling us what's dangerous
he has a history of overlooking real
danger and has been accused
of failing to report abuse that was
happening of college wrestlers
when he was assistant wrestling coach at
ohio state i don't know if i'm supposed
to call it wrestling
but i call it wrestling he's the last
guy to tell us
about who should be telling who should
be listing what is most and least
dangerous anyway
he's horrible jim jordan is sort of the
prototype
of the kooky american politician that
the world
sees and wonders what the hell is wrong
with the united states
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by cal
tech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's time to throw the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of
excellent reviews online from countless
people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video
and you'll get 20 off when you use the
coupon code
pacman and just a quick disclaimer i'm
required
to give these products contain nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical